Speaker 1: Well, after close to, you
know, close to 20 hours of questions from
senators in the Judiciary Committee, the question
and answer phase of Supreme Court nominee Judge
Catanese Brown Jackson are finally over. Those
hours are finally over. That portion has ended
and she will most likely be confirmed as
she should because, as I outlined yesterday,
she is more qualified by the standard definitions
to be on the Supreme Court than any of the nine
justices currently on the court. But this doesn't
mean that Republican senators on the Judiciary
Committee didn't pull out every possible dirty
trick in the book that they could think of.
And unfortunately, a lot of these tactics were
effective. This morning I appeared on the right
wing Daily Wire Show hosted by Michael Knowles,
and his and his audience think that it's been
incredible what Ted Cruz has done, what Marsha
Blackburn did by saying, Can you define woman
and on and on and on so she'll be confirmed,
and she should be. But these rhetorical pond
scum techniques really do work, and I want
to look at a couple more from yesterday at
one point trying to again draw Judge Jackson into
one of these rhetorical black holes on identity.
Ted Cruz went down a line of questioning where
he said, Could I choose to be Asian for an hour
and then go back to being Hispanic? Take a look at
this and again, to the right love to this stuff.
Speaker 2: But the question was let me ask.
Under the modern leftist sensibilities, if if?
I decide right now that that I'm a
woman. Then apparently, I'm a woman,
does that mean that I would have Article three
standing to challenge a gender based restriction?
Speaker 3: Senator, to the extent that you are
asking me about who has the ability to bring
lawsuits based on gender or those kinds of
issues are working their way through the
courts and I'm not able to comment on them.
Speaker 2: OK, if I can change my gender,
if I can be a woman and then an hour
later, if I decide I'm not a woman anymore,
I guess I would lose. Article three Standing
Speaker 1: Now, remember that all of these
sometimes mild and sometimes more extreme
instances of transphobia. They're all based
on imaginary worlds in which people would do
this. You know, I don't want to get off on
it. We're going to get back to Ted Cruz taking an
hour to be an Asian man in a second. But I think
it's important to remember that with all of these
things about bathrooms and what if I put someone
the other day left a voicemail asking me about
what if I put on a wig so that I can then go into
the women's room? It's still against the law to
harass people or to stalk people or whatever. And
the idea that people are going around trying to
figure out, how can I spend a really long time in
bathrooms out in public? This is not. Fortunately,
this is not actually the way people operate in
the world. And when people do have nefarious goals
for things they want to do to others in bathrooms,
it doesn't matter whether you're wearing a
wig or the gender of your identity it. We have
rules against treating people certain ways, and
these are all red herrings. But let's continue.
Speaker 2: Tell me, does that same principle apply
to other protected characteristics? For example,
I'm an asthmatic man. Could could I decide
I was an Asian man? Would I have the ability
to be an Asian man and challenge Harvard's
discrimination because I made that decision? Hmm.
Speaker 3: Senator, I'm not able to answer your
question. You're asking me about hypotheticals and
Speaker 2: how you would assess
standing if I if I came in and said
I have decided I identify as an Asian man.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, this is such a
bad. It's ignorant or bad faith. I don't want to
call it one, if it might be the other. But when
it comes to the court, and if she's interviewing
here for a role as a Supreme Court justice, we
should think about how these issues are dealt with
by a court. And courts have to decide extremely
narrowly based on the facts of a particular
situation and the complaint of the party bringing
the case and the idea that we just need to
vaguely define whether Ted Cruz could be Asian
for an hour. Is it? It's very stupid and it's not
based in reality now. Ted Cruz also criticized
Judge Jackson because she didn't answer what it
means, what the definition of woman is, which
Speaker 2: I think you're the only Supreme Court
nominee in history who's been unable to answer
the question What is a woman?
Speaker 1: Now I went back and looked,
and I've not found any other Supreme Court
nominee in history who was asked to please
define a woman. So just bad faith trash all over.
We'll look at one more clip of radical Republican
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham. He
stormed out on the first day of questions.
He also did it yesterday after making a bunch
of other bad faith arguments. Check this out.
Speaker 2: Your view of how to deter child
pornography is not my view. I think you're
doing it wrong, and every judge who does what
you're doing is making it easier for the children
to be exploited. If you're on a computer right
now, looking at a kid in a sexually compromising
situation and you get caught, I hope nobody
gives you a break because you used a computer.
The conduct has been described as reprehensible,
and I think everyone in this room agrees.
And the fact of the matter is that I am
co-sponsor of your bill, the Earn It Act,
and I believe that we should be doing our
job here. But part of our job, we have failed
in responding to the changing circumstances that
face this crime. What is it? Been 15 or 16 years?
She is currently not an outlier in sentencing
70 percent of the federal judges face the same
dilemma and wonder why Congress has
failed to act and when it will act.
This is our fault part. Partially, it is senator,
to be honest with you, it is. We have to upgrade
these guidelines and decide whether we're going
to stick with the Supreme Court decision that
they're not mandatory. Thank you, Senator
Feinstein. Thank you very much, Mr. Chairman.
Speaker 1: And then out goes Lindsay
storming out once again. So listen,
here's what it fundamentally comes down to. Judge
Jackson is more qualified than anybody currently
on the court. Based on her experience and we
looked at it yesterday, sentencing commission
judge at different levels, et cetera, et cetera.
They don't have anything. They've got nothing on
her. And so this is what they've done, focus
on issues that are completely separate from
the way that a Supreme Court actually evaluates
standing and facts of cases and to grandstand
in this way. And they're pathetic and she deserves
to be confirmed. And I believe she will be